[Music]
i first learned of luma muffler's work
when i saw her ted talk a number of
years ago and i was absolutely inspired
by her and her story
the ted talk was called don't feel sorry
for refugees
believe in them
and that's exactly what her message was
it was one of empowerment
luma has gone on to coach a soccer team
just for refugees called of course the
fujis
and she started the first accredited
school just for refugees
the schools are spreading across the
united states and she's giving refugees
new hope to rebuild their communities
this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
luma thanks so much for taking the time
i first learned about you and your work
from your ted talk like so many
and
i was brought to tears and inspired
by your work you know i'm a sucker for
people who devote their lives to the
service of others
you could have just focused on yourself
you made a life for yourself here you
figured things out for yourself here
what made you turn around and want to
give back to the kids i mean i think it
was timing like i i had been focusing on
myself i had um
you know right after college you know
tried to figure out what i wanted to do
i'd been waiting tables clerked at a law
firm opened up my own cafe i was like
i'm gonna you know live the american
dream
and it wasn't working out like it just
wasn't and i think a lot had to do was
because it wasn't what i wanted to do
and i accidentally made a wrong turn saw
some kids playing soccer in a parking
lot and it reminded me of home like i
grew up in the in jordan
and you know the minute you can start
walking you learn how to play soccer and
it's what i needed that day i
saw these kids outside i wanted to play
i
grabbed my soccer ball and
jumped in and i know for a lot of people
it's like kind of creepy you're like
what is an adult person like jumping
into a kid's game but
all over the world that's how you make
friends and how you build communities
around you know that beautiful game the
boys i first met were from afghanistan
sudan and liberia
they were shocked when i could pronounce
their names correctly you know they're
like where are you from and you know i
was like no i was born in jordan i'm
muslim like that's why i can say you're
properly and
started making excuses to leave work
early so i could play with them and then
got to know more about their lives you
know it's like we started a soccer team
i'd been coaching club soccer for a
while and after practice some of the
kids would be like coach can you help us
with our homework initially i was
dismissive go get your parents or your
sister to help you not realizing that
their parents were illiterate not only
in english but in their own languages
and
they kind of just exposed me to
everything that was wrong you know
especially in the education
system like i was helping a kid with his
homework and they would have grade level
work
even though they'd only been in school
six months like total in their life
and so they're expected to do
fractions and multiplications when they
didn't even know the number order i had
some kids that were at romeo and juliet
and couldn't read a picture book and
what was even more shocking was that
they all got a's and b's and i was like
how are you getting a's and b's if you
can't read or write and it shook me so
how were they getting a's and b's if
they couldn't read and write they didn't
cause trouble in class teachers have too
many kids
how do you teach a kid at the
kindergarten level with a kid at the
eighth grade level
some teachers don't expect much from our
community the point is they weren't
getting an education
and these are kids who had come to the
united states
under various stresses at various ages
some of them may have had some education
back home but probably because they left
war touring countries or other stresses
education was the last thing on the
priority list survival i assume is
number one
yeah survival uh you know first it's
fleeing your country you're getting to
safety and then once you get safety it's
eating right like you're not thinking
about school you're thinking about how
can my family eat so you play soccer
with these kids you start the is it a
team or a league so i start a team the
fuji's right fuji's yeah
a take on refugees yes like let's
reclaim the word
and you start with one team siblings
want to join you end up being three
teams and then four teams and
um then after school uh tutoring
so it's like a backward design
and then summer programming and then
realizing that this was a band-aid like
yeah we felt good
when we went out played games but the
reality did not change our kids still
lived in poverty
that cycle was not going to be broken
the majority of their day they spent an
environment where they were not set up
for success
and regardless of how good of an
after-school program or soccer team
you're in that can only do so much
and so it's like if this was my kid what
would i do i'd send them to school that
could meet their needs
there wasn't a school i couldn't afford
private school
it was actually cheaper to start a
school than send a kid to private school
so where is your school
so we have a school in right outside of
atlanta and our second school's in
columbus ohio and how do kids get in you
apply
i had this issue when we were going
through accreditation and um
you know they're like what's your
application process i was like well we
take them out on the field and we have a
tryout and they're like you can't have
an athletic tryout like that's illegal
you can't do that for a
middle in high school it's like it's not
an athletic tryout like we have the kids
come out
we run them for like the first two days
of tryouts it's three back-to-back days
first two days is all conditioning and
we're looking for the kid who's going to
continue is going to push themselves
who's going to show up on time on the
third day we scrimmage we're looking for
the kid who helps others soccer is a
team sport and a lot of this has to do
with the work that we're going to ask
them to do is hard and we want them to
show up and regardless of what they're
facing they can get through it we're not
looking for the most athletic kid we're
looking for the kid that is hungry that
wants out that wants something different
then it's like whomever survives right
and now it's gone now it's like okay if
you survive tryouts you're getting in
then we do an academic test
and we take the lowest performing kid
because they're the ones that need it so
it's kind of like the flip of what a
typical school looks for
so how many kids do you have in each
school
we have almost 200 in georgia and about
80 in columbus amazing and how long have
the schools been going columbus for
three years atlanta for 14. you've built
a remarkable culture in these schools
because you're looking for grit you're
looking for accountability you're
looking for
teamwork it reminds me a little bit of a
story i heard about the navy seals and
i've shared this story before
a former navy seal was asked what kind
of person makes it into the seals
and he said i can't tell you who makes
it in but i can tell you who doesn't
make it in he says the star college
athlete who's never really been tested
to the core of his being none of those
guys make it in he said the preening
leader who likes to delegate everything
none of those guys make it in he says
the the ones who show up with bulging
muscles and tattoos to prove how tough
they are none of those guys make it in
he says some of the guys who make it
into the seals are skinny and scrawny
and you'll see them
shivering out of fear but what they all
have in common is when they're
emotionally exhausted
when they're physically exhausted when
they have nothing left to give
they are able to dig down deep inside
themselves some way somehow to find the
energy to help the guy next to them
those are the guys you want on your team
right and so what i think is magical is
you're creating a school
how the world should operate
it's not just about personal ambition
but it's how do we get through this not
how i get through this it's how do we
get a's not how do i get an a have you
ever watched the great british baking
show yeah i love that show why do you
love it i love it because it's what
competition should look like like
they're all competing it is a
competition there is a winner and yet
they root for each other they help each
other some of them are unabashed about
their ambition i would like to win they
say yeah and yet still
you see them help each other and that's
kind of how it should be which is the
ability to help each other succeed in
the same competition doesn't preclude us
from advancing and winning ourselves and
so why not help
like you can still do well if you help
others and we've drifted so far away
from that you know yeah i find it ironic
you know this country
is basically a country of immigrants you
know almost everyone here except for
native americans came here looking for
opportunity or running away from
something awful that we seem to have
moved
away from that immigrant mentality
that we're all in this together that it
takes
a group of us a community to to look out
for each other and try and build each
other up and
and grow as individuals and as a group
and it's
kind of ironic that it's taking a group
of refugees to remind us of where we
came from and
show us how we should be living
yeah i mean it's ironic in so many ways
right but it's
i think what we show is like the best of
america and the best of the east you
know how do those two come together like
individualistic
and community practices like it's just
like you said if you help someone else
doesn't mean you're gonna get less
right or you're not gonna benefit right
but
i just feel like recently it's like well
if someone gets something then i'm not
getting it it's like nope we've got
enough for everyone
and you're always going to be learning
you know just like you always learn from
losing and competing against teams who
are better than you it doesn't mean you
haven't won
it means
there's more things to work on and
other ways to look at it right like it's
life is a kind of competition where
multiple people can win simultaneously
just because you win doesn't mean
somebody has to lose so now i'm really
interested in the graduates you're
producing what did your school prepare
them for did some of them go to college
i'm so curious the kinds of lives that
they're living some of them went to
college
some of them have finished college some
went to community college
some of them went right to work
when we asked kids hey what is it that
you want to do after you push a little
bit we'll usually get the typical answer
i want to be a doctor lawyer engineer
and you just keep asking like what is it
that you want
and they'll say well i just want to take
care of my mom
it's like all right that's one we can
take care of right so let's find things
that you are good at things that you
love doing and so that's why we don't
have one
portrait of a graduate right can you
tell me a story of a specific student
whose experience
perfectly captures
what you're trying to do i think there's
two so the first one is one of my somali
players graduated high school ended up
doing an aviation
mechanics program in middle georgia he
loved working with his hands he loved
fixing things uh he didn't want to sit
in a classroom all day so that was like
a perfect match for him
he has two brothers who were deaf and
felt he needed to take care of everyone
and after he finished his program he
started being a valet at one of the
atlanta restaurants to support his
family his dad had been diagnosed with
cancer
he needed to earn money to pay the bills
and support and make sure his younger
siblings were in school
and then
had a breakdown and wanted to figure out
how to practice what he had studied and
figured out a way to pay for his tests
that he had to take and he ended up
getting a job with american airlines
loved what he did started earning money
moving his way up but the one moment
that stands out to me is he sent me a
picture one day
and it was a house that looked very
familiar
i was like are you in my old
neighborhood and
it was a picture of a house down the
street from where i used to live
and he's like
yeah i said why send me a picture of
this house not my house
and he's like no i just bought it for my
mom
wow and he was like so happy and so
proud and that was what he wanted to do
he wanted to take care of his mom
he never gave up and he always saw light
like there's always hope
and i think it's very easy with our kids
to pigeonhole it and say it's so bad
it's so terrible look at what i've been
through look at what my family's been
through you know they left somalia they
came here
his dad gets cancer and passes it's like
one thing after the other
and
it's like nope we can do it we're so
lucky and it's his persistence and his
optimism
he wants to take care of others it's
family like that's what you do you take
care of each other
one of the things that i'm learning from
you is that service the
service-mindedness
can indeed and is taught it's it's not
because
of their experience but they're in an
environment in which teamwork and
service is the standard and so it's it's
in them
how do we scale
what you're teaching your kids
so that more than just
fujis can
learn this magical lesson but rather
that we can bring these lessons to
all schools in america i mean i think
it's like a change of mindsets because i
initially i'd say okay we should
introduce team sports every kid should
play it all the time right
but with the wrong coach it's gonna be a
win at all costs right not every kid
plays not everyone learns um not
everyone supports each other
when we get report cards at school uh we
read them in front of each other the
entire school so you get up and you read
your report card
and it's not to be like oh this one has
an f i have an a it's like one of my
teammates is struggling
what do i need to do to help them and so
you see if a student gets an f their
neighbor is now
making sure they wake up and go to
school on time
if they're acting out in class the
entire class stop you've got to behave
because you've got to pass
we're all responsible for that f
we focus so much on well we're
celebrating all the a's we have honor uh
role and all that but it's like
why aren't we paying attention to those
that need our help and why aren't we
equipping other kids who are doing well
that they have a responsibility to help
not to be like well i have an a that's
great because now we're not going to be
competing for college rank like
valedictorian all that
so every kid is responsible to read
their report card out to the entire
school and
i know what so many people are thinking
as they hear that which is how
humiliating for the ones who don't do
well
i would never want my kid to do that
because i wouldn't want them to be
humiliated
i want to know the speech you give each
time
before the report cards are read out
our team is only as strong as our
weakest player
and our schools
are only as strong as our weakest
students and if anyone in our community
needs help we help them
and if anyone is struggling it is
everyone's responsibility in this room
because we all want to say hey i was
responsible in helping that kid would
get that a right
but you're also responsible for that kid
getting that f
and that's every single person in that
room
from the coaches to the teachers to
their classmates to their friends in
every grade
and they get up and they read it
and
you feel like you've got i mean it's a
community but this entire team behind
you
because sometimes kids get f's or when
we fail you know we like
lock the doors we're so embarrassed we
don't want to talk about it
you know unless we can um
like some tech person where that's
celebrated you failed but now here's
your redemption story right
but why aren't we teaching that at a
young age well here's your f
here's how you can get out of it it's
not the end of the world
and so when our kids experience any type
of failure they know what they need to
do to get out of it
we have one kid like he had been in the
country less than
four weeks and he got up to read his
report card and all f's
but he came up to read it he couldn't
read
the paper was flipped upside down he had
it facing
never been in a school before and
you know no one said anything
and then six weeks later he's getting up
to read
and there's a one f
a couple of c's one b
um and the entire school
started clapping
and every kid in that room
had seen him learn to read
because of the effort everybody put
behind that
and that was progress right and then it
continued to be that
and i think when you know that
uh you are part of a community then you
are held more accountable how do we do
that in work because what you're talking
about is honesty what you're talking
about is candor what you're talking
about is i see myself as part of a
community as part of a team as part of a
company i cannot be expected to succeed
by myself and as you said by putting so
much celebration on only on those who
succeed it it creates a pressure to
either lie hide and fake or
or use any means
to get that high grade for fear of
slipping or fear of looking down which
could lead to some sort of rather
unethical ways of getting those a's yeah
kids who are constantly constantly
cheered and succeeded because they're
straight a students all the time and
people say to them oh i knew you'd do
well you're so smart i knew you do well
you're so smart but later in life a
significant number of them actually
don't overachieve because they're afraid
of falling off the pedestal
average students who are rewarded for
their growth
you know good job you really move that c
to a b well done i knew you had it in
you they do much better in life because
for them there's no pedestal to fall off
how do we create uh incentive programs
that work
that part of your incentive is helping
someone not just achieving yourself like
one group get you know hits their
numbers we give them a huge bonus
another group misses their numbers we
give them nothing how do we ensure that
the successful group is helping the less
successful group well because you're
part of a bigger team right like you can
pit them against each other for
something that's like a little healthy
but then what are we learning from each
other
and how are we making sure we have a
well-rounded team that everybody
everybody has a role to play
i think you're highlighting something
which is life
is not an individual sport life
is a team sport when we look at data of
individual athletes versus team athletes
for example
michael phelps becomes the most meddled
olympian in history which was his dream
after which depression andre agassi
becomes the most celebrated tennis
player in history after which depression
because they've surrounded themselves
with people only to help them with their
ambition and they find that if they
achieve it and very few actually do
achieve it it doesn't make them feel
better because now they have no friends
and they've got no support structure and
it's very lonely
team athletes don't have that
no and i would even argue that soccer
like it's the only sport where the coach
is not in control you have taught your
players you've trusted them you're maybe
like giving like some inspiration and
like
keeping temperaments down but like i
can't call a timeout i have to trust
that i've taught them and they're gonna
get creative and do what they want and
that's what's beautiful about it is they
have to rely on each other
so soccer is unique here it's not about
all team sports i mean although all team
sports may teach them something you
believe soccer stands head and shoulders
above the rest because as you said it
inherent as team reliance you need all
11 players to to do well one player
can't carry a team you know some people
like well messi can't he can't
lebron can tom brady can
we've seen that happen
but in soccer your whole team your whole
team so you've got to take care of each
other but i do think all team sports
contribute
yeah
the refugee
crisis around the world is gaining more
and more press because it's more and
more dire
people leaving
totalitarian regimes and war-torn places
or places that offer them no opportunity
to provide for their families and they
go off looking for better lives
i'm just curious what your commentary is
what your point of view is
given the state of the world right now
because i assume you are seeing
more people applying to your schools
right
yeah and we're seeing
school districts reach out to us so
that's what we're mapping out is how do
we support school districts instead of
just opening more schools how can we
have them implement our model in their
communities
and learn to understand the different
demographics who are coming in i think
it's a good thing that people are
focused on it right now you know
afghanistan has brought it back front
and center i hope it's not well here it
is for the next few months and then we
move on some days i'm optimistic some
days i'm just
depressed
that the world we're leaving our
children is going to be worse than the
one we were in and that's just like a
number of refugees it's it has not gone
down it hasn't even plateaued it just
keeps going up
and we don't change what we're doing we
don't change how we stop wars
how we um stabilize regions we just
continue repeating history
i mean that's why we're in the position
we're in like i was trying to explain to
my daughter what happened in afghanistan
you know i was like we're trying to help
well he's grandmother get out and
and she's like what happened i said well
we gave it to the taliban
and she looked at me she was like the
taliban the ones who shot malala
and i was like yeah
and she just couldn't understand it and
it's like
it's that simple we know that we don't
agree with brutality and murder and
genocide
and why aren't we putting a stop to it
why aren't we stabilizing countries so
people never have to leave it shouldn't
be like can we take more in it's like no
nobody wants to leave their home that is
not an experience i want anyone to ever
have to do
and so what can we do as a society to
make places more peaceful this
discussion is fraught with irony as you
said the way you help refugees is by
creating a place where they never have
to make the decision to leave
there should be no refugees it should be
a rare thing
not such an epidemic thing
and i i've always like well world war ii
that was going to be the mo where
everybody right and then it was like
which war is going to be like we've had
enough this can't continue yeah i don't
know what needs to happen for people be
like this is not acceptable
do you have a mentor is there someone in
particular you who inspires you or you
look to i have like my grandmother's
voice in my head all the time
she's past but like everything that she
has done and that the way she looked at
life and people and
that's always there where was she from
syria
um so she left with her kids when the
first civil war started back in the 60s
she took care of everyone her family and
her community if anyone came to her door
arab hospitality is
is known to be generous but she actually
lived it never turned anyone away
and was always pushing
like any time i patted myself on the
back she's like what's next what are you
gonna do next i'm like really like
um and i think i have that like when we
uh get together as uh you know our
schools like what did we do well
everybody's all right so what can we do
better and they're like come on i'll
give you five minutes right we're gonna
celebrate it we can't get too
comfortable we can't get too complacent
what can we do better
and pushing people to try things
differently and
what new ways can we reach kids and
bring the material to life
yeah
you are magic i have to tell you i love
what you are doing and i do believe that
your model
serves more than refugees i believe it
serves as a model for how we need to
teach all children and what it means to
be a better human being
we're team animals we're built for team
much more than we are built for
individual you know we're not that
strong and not that smart by ourselves
but as groups we're remarkable
but as you said the team is only as
strong as the weakest player
and so how do we build up our weak
players
you've given me so many ideas about some
of the things that we all can do at work
or with our families
you know to share group accountability
it's it's really magical what you're
doing and i i want you to be wildly
successful because i think your model is
really important thank you and i hope it
spreads
and i hope you help a lot of kids
thank you
[Music]
if you're interested in learning more
about or supporting luma and her work
please visit or consider donating
at fuji's family dot org that's
f-u-g-e-s
family
dot org
if you enjoyed this podcast and would
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then
take care of yourself
take care of each other